the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
talk about gradient descent and the and
its descendants so from the basic
gradient descent formula which we all
know let me just write that down the new
point is the old point we're going
downwards so with a minus sign that's
the step size and we compute the
gradient at X K so we're descending in
the direction of the negative gradient
and that's the basic formula and is in
every book studied so my main reference
for the some of these lectures is the
book by Stephen Boyd and Linden and
Vandenberg and and I mentioned again
professor Boyd is talking in this room
next week Wednesday Thursday and and
he's speaking somewhere on Friday at
4:30 and of course about optimization
and he's a good lecturer yeah very good
okay so there's steepest descent and
I've redrawn my picture from last time
that I'll go over there and look at that
picture but let me say what's coming so
that's pretty standard very standard you
could say then this is the improvement
that is widely used adding in something
called momentum to avoid the zigzag that
we're going to see
and there's another way to do it there's
a Russian guy named Nestor off his
papers are not easy to read but they've
got serious content and one thing he did
was find an alternative to momentum that
also accelerated the the descent so this
produces these both produce faster
descent than the ordinary one okay and
then you know looking ahead that for
problems of machine learning they're so
large that the gradient and we have so
many variables all those weights are
variables all and that could hundreds of
thousands is is not uncommon
so that then the gradient becomes a
pretty big calculation and we don't have
to do it all at once we don't have to
change so xk is a vector of all the
weights or and using and our equations
are the matching the the training data
so we don't have to use all the training
data at once and we don't we take a
batch of training data like one but
that's sort of inefficient in the
opposite direction they do them one at a
time so we don't want to do with them
one at a time but we don't want to do
all all million at a time
so the compromise is a mini batch so
sarcastic gradient descent does a mini
batch at a time a mini batch of of
training of samples training data each
step and it can choose them
stochastically meaning randomly or
sitting more systematically but we do a
batch at a time and that will come after
the
it'll come next week after a marathon of
course on Monday okay so let me just go
back to that picture for a moment but
then the real content of today is this
one with momentum added okay I just I
probably haven't got the picture perfect
yet I'm just not an artist but I think
I'm closer so this is uh those are the
level sets those are the sets f of X
equal constant and in our model problem
f of X is X 1 squared or let's say x
squared plus B y squared equal constants
with small B be below 1 and maybe far
below 1 so those are ellipses those the
equations of an ellipse and that's what
I tried to draw and if B is small then
the ellipses are long and thin like that
and now what's what's the picture you
start with a point X naught and you
descend in the steepest direction so the
steepest direction is perpendicular to
the level set right perpendicular to the
ellipse so you down down down you're
passing through more ellipses more
ellipses more ellipses eventually your
tangent to it seems to me it has to be
tangent I didn't read this but it looks
reasonable to me that the the farthest
in level-set farthest an ellipse you're
tangent to and then you start going up
again so that's the optimal point to
stop to end that step and then where
does the next step go well you're here
you're on an ellipse that's a level set
you want to move in the gradient
direction that's perpendicular to the
level set so you're going down somewhere
here and you're passing again through
more and more ellipses until your
tangent to a
to a smaller ellipse here and and you
see the zig-zag pattern and that zig-zag
pattern is what we see by formula in in
Boyd's book and many other places too
the formula has the there was powers of
a beam of the magic number so we start
at start at the point b1 and follow this
path then the X's are the same B times
this quantity to the case power and
here's that quantity B minus 1 over B
plus 1 so you see for a small B that's
that's a negative number so it's
flipping sign in the X's as we saw on
the pictures
leave that part of the picture is
correct the Y's don't flip sign so this
was XK and when K is 0 we got B YK is I
think is is not flipping a sign so that
looks good and then FK the value of F
also was the same quantity
FK is that same quantity to the case
times f0
so that quantity is all all-important
and so the purpose of today's lecture is
to tell you what the momentum term what
improvement what change that brings in
the basic steepest descent formula I'm
gonna add on another term which is going
to have some give us some memory of the
previous step and so when I do that
I want to track that kind of descent for
for the new for the accelerated descent
and track it and see what improvement
the momentum term brings and so the
final result will be to tell you the
improvement in the produce by the
momentum term maybe while I have your
attention I'll tell you what it is now
and then we'll come the details the
algebra and to me so this is my own
thought it's a miracle that the algebra
which is straightforward you really see
the value of eigenvectors
you know we explain eigenvectors in
class but but here you see why what how
to use them that's is really a good
exercise but to me it's a miracle that
the expression with momentum is very
much like that expression but different
of course the the the decay is a term
that tells you how fast the decay is is
smaller so you're taking K power so so
let me I'll write that down if that's
all right it's I didn't plan to do to
reveal the final result at the beginning
of the lecture but I think you want to
see where we're going so so with
momentum and we have to see what that
means this this term of 1 minus B over 1
plus B becomes changes to
one minus square root of B over 1 plus
square would be so I mentioned that
before but but I don't think I wrote it
down just clearly so the miracle to me
is to get such a nice expression for the
because you'll see the algebra is it
works but it's it's it involves more
terms because of momentum involves doing
a minimization of eigenvalues and yet it
comes out nicely and and then you have
to see the importance of that so let me
I would just take the same example that
I mentioned before if B is 1 over 100
then this is 0.99 over 1.01 oh I think
that these there's a square here 2 K so
if we're so I'll I'll just keep this
square there no big change but but I'm
looking at now here at the square
maybe maybe squares are everywhere you
know ok so so that's close to 1 and now
let's compare that with what we have so
if B is 1 over 100 so I'm taking V to be
1 over 100 then square root of B is 1
over 10 so this is 0.9 0.9 over 1.1
squared and there's a tremendous um
block smaller than that is right
9/10 9 9 / 11 compared to 99 over 101
this one is you know is definitely oh
sorry it's yeah it's this this reduction
factor is well below that one so it's a
good thing it's worth doing and okay
now what is it involved okay so I'll
write down the expression for the for
the sarcastic here we go okay
so here's one way to see it the new X is
the old X minus the gradient and now
comes an extra term which gives us a
little memory well I'm sorry the the
algebra is slightly nicer if I write it
a little bit differently I'll create a
new quantity ZK with a step size okay
okay so if I took ZK to be just the
gradient that would be steepest descent
nothing has changed but instead I'm
gonna take ZK well its leading term will
be the gradient but here comes the
momentum term I add on a multiple beta
one way to do it is of the previous Z so
the Z is the search direction z is the
gradient you're traveling it's the
direction you're moving so it's
different from that direction there that
direction was the gradient this
direction is the gradient correct
corrected by a memory term a momentum
term and one way to interpret that is to
say that that ball is to think of a
heavy ball instead of just a point I
think of a heavy ball it instead of
bouncing back and forth as as as as
uselessly as this one it tends to
it still bounces of course on the sides
of the level sets but it comes down the
valley faster and that's the effect of
this so so you could play with different
adjustment terms different Corrections
so but I'll follow through this one
Nesterov had another way to make a
change in the formula and the there are
certainly others beyond that okay
so how do we analyze that one well
they're the real point is we've sort of
by taking by involving the previous step
we now have a three level method instead
of a two level method you could say
there's this this involves only level k
plus 1 and level K the formulas now
involve k plus 1 k and k minus 1 it's
just like going from a first-order
differential equation to a second-order
differential equation
it's it's I'm not really thinking that K
is a is a time variable but in the
analogy K could be a time variable so
that here we had like a first-order
equation if I wanted to model that
that's sort of a DX DT coming in there
equal a gradient and and these models
are highly useful and and developed for
sort of a continuous model of steepest
descent a continuous motion instead of
the instead of the discrete motion okay
so that would that's continuous model
for that guy would be a first order in
time for this one it'll be second order
in time and second order equations of
course and the be constant coefficients
in our model problem and the thing about
a second-order equation that we all know
there's a momentum term a a damping term
you could say in multiplying the first
derivative so that's what that's what a
second-order equation offers is the
inclusion of a damping term which isn't
present in the in the original
first-order okay so how do we analyze
this I have to so how do you analyze
second-order differential equations you
write them as a system of two first
order equations so that's exactly what
we're going to do here in the discrete
case we're going to see of course we
have two equations and their first order
and and we can let me play with them for
a moment to to make them good okay so
I'm gonna have so this will go to 2
first order equations in which the first
one I'm just gonna copy XK plus 1 is XK
minus at step size ZK whew yeah ok yeah
ok time the previous times type here the
the next time step on the left okay so I
just copied that now this one I'm going
to increase K by 1 so in order to have
that looking to match this I'll write
that as Z K plus 1 and I'll bring the
case ain't grad F k plus 1 equal beta ZK
that look with you I just in this in
this thing instead of looking at it at
ki I went to K plus 1 and I put the K
plus 1 terms on one side okay so now I
have a a
and let's see let's remember we're doing
our the model we're doing is f equal up
1/2 X transpose s X so the gradient of F
is s X so what I've written there or
gradient is really I know what that
gradient is so that's really s xk plus
okay okay how to analyze that what
happens as K as K travels forward one
two three four five we have a constant
coefficient problem at every step the XZ
variable is getting multiplied by a
matrix so here's X Z at k plus 1 and
over here will be X Z at step K and I
just have to figure out what matrix is
multiplying here and here okay and I
guess here I see it if the first
equation has a 1 and a minus s looks
like in the first row and it has a beta
in the second row and here the first
equation has a 1 0 in that row and then
a minus s I'll put in minus s
multiplying XK plus 1 and then the one
that multiplies ZK plus 1 is that all
right
sorry I've got 2 SS and I didn't draw
that one didn't write that one in large
enough and I'd plan to erase it anyway
this is the this is the step size this
this is the matrix but but it's it's not
it's not quite fitting it's placed this
is the point where I'm gonna use eigen
values I'm gonna follow an I follow each
eigen value that's the whole point when
I follow each eigen value
each eigenvector I should say I'll
follow each eigenvector of s so let's
let's do that so so I can vectors of s
what are we gonna call those lambda
probably so s X equal lambda X I think
that's what's coming or Q I to do things
right I want to remember that s is a
positive definite symmetric matrix
that's why I called it s instead of a so
I really should call the eigen it
doesn't matter but to be on the ball let
me call the eigen vector Q and the eigen
value lambda okay okay so now I want to
I want to follow this eigen vector so
I'm supposing that X K is some C K times
Q I'm assuming that X is in the tracking
this eigen vector and I'm gonna assume
that ZK is some other constant times Q
everybody do you see that's a vector and
that's a vector and I want scalars I
want to attract just scalar C K and D K
so that's really what I have here is
this was a little tricky because X here
is a vector and two components are n
components I didn't want that I really
wanted just to track an eigen vector
once I've settled on the direction Q
everything is all vectors are in the
direction of Q so so we just have
numbers see indeed a track okay so I'm
gonna rewrite this
correctly as yeah well let me keep keep
going with this little formula then what
will I needed an SX what will s xk be if
if xk is in the direction of the eigen
vector Q and its CK what happens when I
multiply by yes q was an eigen vector so
the multiplying by s gives me I can
value right so it's C K lambda Q
everything is a multiple of Q and it's
only those multiples I'm looking for the
Seas and the DS and then the lambda
comes into the S term yeah I think
that's probably all I need to to do this
and then the gradient yeah so that's the
gradient of course this is the gradient
of F okay so instead of this let me just
write what's what's happening if I'm
tracking the coefficients CK plus 1 and
DK plus 1 then what I really meant to
have there is 1 0 and minus s is a minus
lambda is that right yeah when I
multiply the eigenvector by s I'm just
kidding oh it's a lambda times the CK
yeah lambda times the CK that's good I
think that that's the left-hand side of
my equation and on the right hand side I
have here that's 1 and this was the
scalar the step size and this was the
other coefficient it's the SN beta so I
want to choose what's my purpose now
that gives me the
what happens at every step to the C and
D so I want to choose the land the the
two things that I have I'm free to
choose our s and beta so that's my big
big job choose s and beta okay now I to
make oh let me just shape this thing up
by month by multiplying the inverse of
that and get it over here so that well
really you'll see everything so CK plus
one DK plus one what's the inverse of
one zero
oh I don't think I wanna that would have
a tough time finding an inverse it was a
one wasn't it yeah okay so I want to
multiply by the inverse of that matrix
to get it over here and what's the
inverse of 1 1 minus lamda it's 1 1 plus
lambda so that the inverse brought it
over here times this matrix 1 0 beta and
minus the step size that's what
multiplies C KD K so we have these
simple beautiful steps which which come
from tracking one eigenvector makes the
whole problem scalar so I multiply those
two matrices in our I finally get the
matrix that I really have to think about
1 0 times that'll be 1 minus s lambda 1
times that will be a lambda there and
minus lambda s plus beta beta minus
lambda s that's the matrix that we see
at every step let me call that matrix Oh
so I've done some algebra more than I
would always do in a lecture but it's
really my I wouldn't do it if it wasn't
nice algebra what's the conclusion the
conclusion is that with the momentum
term with this number beta available to
choose as well as s the step the
coefficient of the eigenvalue
eigenvector is multiplied at every step
by that matrix r r is that matrix and of
course that matrix involves the
eigenvalue yep so we have to think about
what what do we want to do now we want
to choose beta and s to make our as
small as possible right we want to make
our as small as possible and we're free
to choose beta and s but we but our
depends on lambda so I'm going to make
it as small as possible over the whole
range of possible lambdas so so let me
so now here we really go so we have
lambda between some these are these are
the eigen eigen value of s and what we
know what's what's reasonable to know is
a lower bound it's a positive this is a
symmetric positive definite matrix a
lower bound and an upper bound for
example and M was B and M was one in
that two-by-two problem and this is what
we know that the eigen values are
between M&M and the ratio of
m2m well if I buy right this is the this
is the key quantity and what's it called
lambda max divided by lambda min is the
condition number right this is all
sometimes written Kappa Greek letter
Kappa the condition number of s and when
that's big that then the problem is
going to be harder when that's one that
then the matrix is just a multiple of
the identity matrix and the problem is
trivial when this when when when capital
in it m and small m are the same then
that's saying that the largest and
smallest eigen values are identical that
that the matrix is a multiple of the
identity that's the condition number one
but but the bad one is when it's 1 over
B in our example and it and that could
be very large okay that's where we have
a problem let me just insert about the
ordinary gradient descent of course the
textbooks find a estimate for how fast
that is and of course it depends on that
number
yeah so it depends on that number and E
right you exactly saw how it depended on
that number right but now we have a
different problem and we're gonna finish
it okay so what's my job I'm gonna
choose s and beta to get to keep the the
eigen values of R so let's give the
eigen values of RNA so R let's say R has
eigen values
II won that depends on on the lambda and
the s and the beta and E - so those are
the eigenvalues of our just giving a
letter to to them so what's our job we
want to choose s and beta to make those
eigenvalues as small as possible right
small eigenvalues if r has small
eigenvalues its powers see we ever every
step multiplies by r so the convergence
rate with momentum is depends on the
powers of our getting small fast it
depends on the eigenvalues being small
we want to minimize the largest
eigenvalue so I'll say the maximum of e
1 and each and E 2 that's our job
minimize we want to choose s and beta to
minimize the largest eigenvalue because
if there's one small eigenvalue but the
other is big then the other one is going
to kill us so we have to get both
eigenvalues down and of course those
depend on lambda e 1 depends on lambda
so we have a little algebra problem and
this is what I described as a miracle
the fact that this little algebra
problem the eigenvalues of that matrix
e1 and e2 which depend on lambda in some
in some way and we want to make both e1
and e2 small the maximum of those of
them and we have to do it for all the
eigen all the eigenvalues lambda because
we have to we're now thinking we've been
tracking each eigenvector so that gave
us 1 so this is for all possible lambda
oh so we have to decide what do I mean
by all pasta
lambda and I mean all lambda that are
between some M&M there is a beautiful
problem you have a two-by-two matrix you
can find it it find its eigenvalues its
it they depend on lambda and what we all
we know about lambda is it's between m
and and capya and also they also depend
on s and beta the two parameters we can
choose and we want to choose those
parameters so that for for all the all
the possible eigenvalues the larger of
the two eigenvalues will be as small as
possible that's it's a little bit of
algebra but it's do you see that that's
the tricky that I shouldn't say tricky
because it comes out that's that this is
the one that is a miracle in the in the
simplicity of the solution okay and I'm
gonna effect maybe I'll move over here
to write the answer okay and I just want
to say that miracles don't happen so
often in math there's you know all of
mathematics the whole point of math is
to explain miracles so there is a
there's something to explain here and I
don't have my finger on it yet because
anyway it happens so let me tell you
what the right s and the right beta and
the resulting minimum eigen value are so
again they depend on little m and Big M
that's a very nice feature which we
expect and that is and they depend on
the ratio okay so that ratio alright
let's let's see it okay so the best s
the S optimal has the formula two over
square root of lambda max that's the
square root of M and the square root of
M Squared amazing okay and beta optimal
turns out to be the square root of M
minus the square root of little m over
the square root of M plus the square
root of little M all the squared of
course we know what these numbers are 1
and beta in our model problem that's
where I'm gonna get this square root of
this is 1 minus the square sorry B this
is 1 minus the square root of B in fact
ya for our for our example well let me
just write what they would be 2 over 1
plus square root of B Square and 1 minus
would be over 1 plus square you see
where this is 1 minus square root of B
as a beginning to appear now it appears
in the solution of this problem and then
I have to tell you what the what how
small did do these these optimal choices
make the eigenvalues of our right this
is what we're really paying attention to
because it's the eigen values that that
matrix tells us what happens at every
step and the its eigen values have to be
small to get fast convergence so how
small are they well they involve this
yeah so it's the number that I've seen
so so in this case the ease the
eigenvalues
of our that's the iterating matrix are
below that now we're now you're gonna
see that one - were to be over 1 plus
we're to be I think maybe squared let me
just see yeah yeah it happens to come
out that number again so that's the
conclusion that was the right choice of
s and beta by adding this look-back term
look back one step you get this
improvement and it's it happens you see
it in practice of course you'll see it
exactly and so you you do the job to use
momentum now I'm going to mention what
the Nesterov Nesterov had a slightly
different way to do it and i'll tell you
what that is but it's the same idea get
a second thing so let's see if I can
find that yeah nestor oh ok ok here we
go
so let me bring Nestor offs a name down
so that that's the basically what I
wanted to say about number one and when
you've seen this trough you'll see that
it's a similar idea of involving the
previous time value ok there are very
popular methods in use now for machine
learning that involves by a simple
formula all the previous values by by
sort of just by an addition of a bunch
of terms so it's really it
so it's it goes under the names ADA ADA
grad or others those of you who already
know about machine learning will know
what I'm speaking about and I'll say
more about those yeah but it doesn't
involve a separate coefficient for each
previous value or that would be a
momentous amount of work so so now I
just want to tell you what Nesterov is
and then we were good ok mr. roffe's
idea let me bring that down
shoot this up bring down because he had
an idea that you might not have thought
of somehow the momentum idea was pretty
natural to use that previous value and
actually I would like to know what
happens if you use two previous values
or three previous values can you then
get improvements on this this
convergence rate by going back two steps
or three steps if I use the analogy with
ordinary differential equations maybe
you know so right so so there are
backward difference formulas do you know
about those four those would be in
MATLAB software and all other software
backward differences so maybe you go
back two steps or four steps if you're
doing planetary calculations if you're
an astronomer you go back maybe seven or
eight steps to get super high accuracy
so that doesn't seem to have happened
yet but it should happen here to go back
more but but Nesterov will has it has
this different way to go back so his
formula is XK plus one the new way
is YK so he's introducing something a
little different - s radiant f @ YK I'm
a little surprised about that YK but
this is the point here that the gradient
is being evaluated at some different
point and then he has to give a formula
for that for those to track those wise
so the Y's are like the X's but they're
shifted a little bit by some term and
beta would be fine Oh No yeah beta have
we got Nesterov here yes mister off has
a factor gamma in yeah so I all right
let me let me try to get this right okay
all right on the previous line I've
written the whole nestdrop thing here
let's see nice drop completely and then
they'll break then this is the step that
breaks it into two first order but
you'll see the main formula here XK plus
1 is XK and then a beta times XK minus
XK minus 1 so that's like a momentum
term and then a typical gradient but now
here's Nesterov speaking up this trough
evaluates the gradient not at XK not at
XK minus 1 but it is home mr. Oz point
like so this is Nesterov say my favorite
point gamma XK minus XK minus 1 some
point part way along that step so it so
this point because gamma is going to be
some non integer this evaluation point
of for the gradient of F
is a little unexpected and weird because
it's not a mesh point it's somewhere
between okay yep yep and then that so
that involves XK plus 1 XK and XK minus
1 so it's a second-order there's a
second-order method here we're going to
it to analyze it we're going to go
through this same process of writing it
as two first-order steps to first two
single step to one step from k to k plus
1 a a coupled one-step thing follow that
same thing through and then the result
is a same factor appears for him
the same factor this is also so this the
point is this is for momentum and
Nesterov with with some with some
constant difference different by some
constant but the key quantity is that
one and that appears in both so so so I
don't propose of course to repeat these
steps for an ester off but you see what
you see what you could do you see that
it involves K minus 1 K in k plus 1 you
write it as you follow an eigen vector
you write it as a coupled system of
that's a one-step that has a matrix you
find the matrix you find the eigen
values of the matrix you make those
eigenvalues as small as possible and you
have optimized their coefficients in
Nesterov ok that's that's sort of a lot
of algebra that's at the heart of
accelerated gradient descent and of
course it's worth doing because it's a
tremendous saving in the in the in the
convergence rate ok anybody running in
the marathon or just watching it's
possible to run you know anyway I'll see
you after the marathon next Wednesday
and professor Boyd will also see you